with Gojo apparently dying in Jutsu
kaisen many fans are refusing to accept
his death and they are theorizing that
Gojo will come back to life in one way
or another some believe that he will
return as a vengeful spirit because his
ego simply can't handle the idea of
losing to sukuna the man who believes
that throughout Heaven and Earth he
alone is the honored one can't accept
not being the strongest so he might
return as a curse that is the
personification of the human ego others
believe that Gojo will just surpass his
limits return to his body and manage to
heal it we know that Yuji was brought
back to life after his body was dead for
a long time so maybe Gojo can do
something similar because he is the goat
finally some fans think that Yuji will
use his special Soul manipulation
abilities to save Gojo from Death if you
want to know more about yuji's New Soul
Powers click the related video right now
and don't forget to subscribe to anime
uproar